yeah dungeon ryu was really good in his
last outing seven scoreless innings his
fifth scoreless outing of this season he
won his 12th game of the season that
ties him now with garrett cole chris
bassett for the most in the american
league you mentioned the white sox
second time that he's facing him in his
career
strikes out anderson that was a familiar
theme for the blue jays they struck out
16 white sox in the game last night of
course robbie ray had a 14 strikeout
game this high fastball gets anderson
and sets up all of his other pitches and
ball is lined into right but right there
is tayoska hernandez two up two down
there's a line drive but there's simian
behind second
good start for ryu
but carlos has done a great job of
limiting slugging percentage to anybody
that he's faced this year he's been
really good look at his average against
right-handed batters under 200 190 or
excuse me
195 overall
the shet to second cesar hernandez
collects out number one and there's
andrew vaughan at first marcus simeon
one for 11 in the series a double and a
walk
there's a drive to left field get up out
of here and go marcus
jump starts the offense today with his
31st home run of the season that ball
got out of here in a hurry well it's
right in his swing path that's right
where he likes it down and in
sport coat as carlos makes a great play
jumping to make that catch on guerrero
the big cat drop step the kick and the
pitch and a 3-0 swing and a pop-up
shallow right looks like hernandez's
second baseman is going to take it and
he will
got him
another good fastball
two out cesar hernandez
first pitch swinging on a curveball deep
to left smith is at the track and the
wall and it's over the wall hernandez
just got it up and out and this ball
game is tied
and hernandez has his third homer with
the sox number 21 on the year and it's
one to one
there's a called strike three
[Applause]
ground ball big hop for bow at short
they threw wide at first base but vlady
comes off the base and puts the tag on
garcia
ground ball to third another easy play
for espanol threw right on the money
runner at first two down three and two
on robert
a high fly ball out into deep left
center and it is gone
a towering deep fly and i don't even
think he got all of it
oh he did not get all of it it would
have been up there in the restaurant
area that was just so high tough to tell
what it was going to do until you see
the reaction of the outfielders which
was basically nothing aside from looking
up and jogging that direction told us
that one's going to end up going two sox
home runs a 3-1 lead against ryu and now
abreu
3-2 that ball is late to left field
smith's back again and this one's gone
back-to-back home runs robert and abreu
tim says yes sir the socks are up three
do not hang it to the white sox with two
strikes three two they are not going to
miss it
to center field robert is back on it
luis at the track and he's got it
1-1
popped up
andrew vaughn somebody else you got room
they were right
the 2-0 is pounded on the ground at
third easy play garcia not a good throw
but vaughn able to dig it out of the
dirt and the
second and third one out so larry now
[Music]
laser to left field leori garcia that'll
bring two home vaughn scores hernandez
follows and that for garcia is a two-run
double
and suddenly all of yesterday goes in
the rear-view mirror the sox are up six
to one here comes tim with two outs
garcia at second the 1-0 pitch there's a
liner base hit to left garcia around
third will score
it's seven to one
marcus
lines it into left field maguire is
gonna score
he's around third into home and
marcus sivia picks up his second rbi of
the afternoon that'll give him 75 for
the season we have seen light showers at
rogers center in the past but this is a
little more than a light shower
you can see the roof is moving in
position now
but this one kind of snuck up on
everybody
clears this one down the right side
that's going to drop for a base hit
simeon's headed for third he'll stop
there
sign and
they'll see this very often at rogers
center the rain coming down
mid game that's why they're digging out
that landing spot
struck him out a big yes from carlos
sebby zavala right center field grichik
back at the track and the wall and
britchick could not haul it in he
crashed into the scoreboard and it goes
down to the turf and the sox add a run
sevi zavala again lays into one it's an
rbi double and it's eight to two
here's the pitch
swinging a grounder up the middle into
center
zavala scores
it's nine to two
ground ball through the right side
they're gonna wave the runner home
here's the throw to the plate as
kirk comes in to score the white sox
throw it around and now the runners will
go to second and third
what a pitch what a swing bobes [ __ ]
cashes in once again batting with two
outs and a runner in scoring position
nine to five
marcus sibian's had a two-hit game
swinging and drive get out of here ball
get up get up and die
marcus simmons with another home run and
here come the jays
i want to play by lady
everybody's fired up now
guerrero takes a hit away from a menace
maddie guerrero is putting on a show
with the leather over at first he got a
great jump he stayed low he kept his
feet moving two one two out t.a will try
to extend this lead
breaking ball hit in the air but there's
randall what a job by trevor richards he
inherits a couple of base runners and
strands
with two outs
eloy jimenez cranks this ball left
center field it goes and it is out of
here a little cushion for the socks
another home run and it's 10-7
say oscar hernandez
on the ground kimbrell's got it and the
socks secure a split
in toronto it got dicey for a moment
[Applause]